Leader of the pack Augusto Deoliveira became an Internet star...
...after uploading this video of himself walking unleashed dogs through a quiet town,...
...showing an amazing bond with his animals.
Augusto grew up on a farm in Brazil with dozens of dogs.
And he learned from a young age to communicate with them.
Today, he lives, breathes, and even sleeps with his pets,...
...as part of his work, running Griffin Shepherd Kennels.
My dogs know me as part of the pack.
I spend a lot of time with them.
I feed them, I walk them out, I exercise them.
I do everything with them.
I love spending time with my dogs.
I just feel like there's so much I can do with them, I can spend time training them.
I can spend time just taking them places.
I can spend time playing with them.
I never get tired of it.
After a hard day's work,...
...the pack grabbed the first chance they could for a well-earned nap.